so yeah I'm excited to give this talk
here can you guys hear me okay
is it sounding good great so um so yeah
this is going to be about beating
pythons guild and max out your CPUs or
perhaps the more dramatic subtitle I've
given this as scaling Python to three
thousand cores which is a number that I
actually scaled Python to and that is a
number that's so unreasonable that you
could never find that many cores on one
machine which is kind of the point of
this talk so quick background on me as
was mentioned I am a co-founder CTO
parsley parsley is one of the PI data
sponsors we've been presenting various
open source stuff at PI data since 2012
or so what parsley does is we produce
this real-time content analytics
dashboard for some of the web's largest
publishers so it's basically this live
refreshing dashboard that tells them
exactly what web content they publish
online how well that web content is
doing and certain metrics that we
measure and it helps them drill down
into details and roll up pretty like
advanced analytics about how how all
that content is doing on the web it kind
of supports real-time and historical
querying and you know the API is that
we've used to build this dashboard power
anything ranging from a rich front-end
app to a mobile app that summarizes the
data so we've had like a lot of
experience as a company with figuring
out how to make sense of terabytes upon
terabytes of data and then also
visualizing it beautifully for customers
so the challenge that we face this year
was a graph that looked like this and
gave my engineering team nightmares
basically which is what happens when
you've got a hundred and fifty three
terabytes of compressed customer data
that might need to be reprocessed at any
time and it's now growing at a rate of
10 to 20 terabytes per month and so this
is probably a problem that's not unlike
a lot of problems that people in this
audience face
it's the heap of data problem right so
you've you've got this heap of data
you've got your hammer which is Python
and you're wondering how can I get
Python to run over this data and for
certain kinds of calculations you want
to be able to run over
all that data really fast so pythons a
great tool for data processing but as
the title of this talk indicated it gets
a lot of flack for problems like this
mainly because of the Gil so I assume
everyone who came to this talk probably
at least had a small idea of what the
Gil is but does it could I just got a
show of hands of like people who have
run up against Gil problems before okay
so like basically half or more of this
room and the basic set of Gil problems
is that for the most part the Gil the
conventional wisdom about the Gil is
that it eats away at your concurrency
problems or in particular really your
parallelism it gets rid of the ability
of Python to execute code on more than
one core at a time Gil's stand for the
for the people who maybe just came to
this talk out of curiosity Gil stands
for global interpreter lock and it's
basically the lock that the Python
interpreter holds over bytecode
instructions as it's executing those
instructions in serial and what it
basically comes down to and what you can
you know go to if you want to get
background on this is that the Gil
causes all sorts of problems when you
try to do CPU bound threaded work on a
single node if you actually go back to
2010 PyCon 2010 David Beasley gave a
talk where he said I think the talk is
called understanding pythons Gil and he
basically went through and showed just
how crazy the behavior of the Gil is and
multi-threaded CPU bound scenarios
basically what happens is that if you
have two CPUs and two CPU bound threads
what'll end up happening is that one of
the cores will always be spending time
context switching and in contention for
the Gil which will actually slow down
your work so that it'll actually run
worse than if you had actually disabled
one of your cores right it's a
counterintuitive result like if I have
some work that takes ten seconds if I
and I do multi-threaded work on it if I
run those two threads on one core it'll
take ten seconds if I run it on two
cores it might take 30 seconds and the
reason is because the two cores are
essentially fighting free with each
other for the Gil and creating all of
this operating
system overhead as a result now that's
not all the gills really about that's
what that 2010 talk is about but at its
core really like what's going on in the
Python core and this is whether it's pi
PI or or regular Python right now see
Python it doesn't affect as much iron
Python enjoy on but for like the widely
used Python interpreters it basically
means that this mental model is true
which is in one Python process at any
one time only one Python byte code
execution is executing at once
where at once is basically you know
defined by the parallelism of the cores
on your machine so the interesting thing
I've thought about over the years is
that I've had to work around the guild
problem for basically my whole career
because for whatever reason I chose to
do large-scale data problems with Python
right and that just like kind of
dedicates yourself to working around
this problem but something I've noticed
is that I've I've kind of moved away
over the years from multi-threaded
programming altogether partially as a
result of having to work around the Gil
and one kind of nice side effect about
that is I don't deal with multi-threaded
bugs anymore so what I've noticed is
that multi-threaded program and kind of
looks like this in theory but looks like
this in actuality and the thing is that
if you if you have a really high core
machine it can be very tempting to start
to use shared memory and multiple
threads of execution to take advantage
of those cores but you instantly start
to deal with all of the threading issues
like having to set up appropriate
critical sections a mutual exclusion and
all that stuff which if anyone here has
like gone through operating systems
courses and computer science at
university you know that that's like
some of the most challenging programming
you ever do and you're kind of like kind
of proud of yourself when you get a
multi-threaded program to work but you
also kind of say to yourself I hope I
never have to do that again right so the
other thing I kind of heard in the
community over time is a lot of Python
programmers are like hey the guild kind
of stinks but there's this new language
called go and should we just like
rewrite our critical sections that
should be doing multi-core processing
and go and certainly go has a pretty
nice concurrency in parallel
a model but I actually point these same
Python programmers to this quote by the
creator of go which is don't communicate
by sharing memory share memory by
communicating and I think that this is
like the core to how I've been able over
the years to get around ever having to
do multi-threaded programming again
because what I've noticed is that I'm
able to get really multi nice multi-core
machines on Amazon ec2 for example like
here's a 32 core machine and if I write
a like appropriately multi processed
program in Python I can light up these
32 cores and I can do that pretty
effectively but what I noticed is that
when I have a hundred and fifty-three
terabytes of data to process through I
realize that I'm gonna need a bigger
boat right like the 32 cores on that
machine don't help me what I actually
need is three machines that have 32
cores each or maybe 50 or maybe a
hundred and once you start doing that
you realize that shared memory
multi-core processing isn't even an
option anymore
right once you start going multi-core
multi node you really have to move into
fast functions running in parallel
across your cluster so what I'm going to
do in this talk for this section is I'm
going to actually take a real-world
problem that we worked on which is a
real world problem that you would face
multi-core processing problems with and
I'm basically going to work walk us up
the complexity curve of hey I need to
run this on a heap of data what are my
options in Python right now what are my
best options and what can I do to get to
where I need to be to reprocess this
data quickly so on the left you see a
Python program that has code in state
and you see a server which right now
will just look at one server that has
two cores on it and basically I've got a
heap of URLs might be a big list and I
want to use the Python 3 function which
is URL Lib dot parse dot URL parse which
I thought they cleaned up the standard
library in Python 3 why does that sound
so repetitive now anyway so what I want
to do is I want to map URL parse over
all those URLs and I want to do that
really fast ok well if you know anything
about the Gil you'll know that or even
just about Python in general you'll know
that running
people map against this will just light
up one of those server quarters right
that's all I'm gonna get so now I'm
saying to myself well URL Lib dot parse
that URL parse I looked into the code
it's actually really crappy Python pure
Python code it's really slow maybe I
could speed it up maybe I can get really
fast URL parse running on a single core
so we actually did that at parsley
because this is a real function that we
had to you know optimize we run this
across all of our data set we found that
the slowest part of the standard
libraries URL parse method is this
function parse qsl and we rewrote it in
scythe on who here has already used
scythe on before okay a few you so
scythe ons really great for those who
haven't used it you can take pure Python
code and you can add little type
annotations to it like this function
returns a list and this function has
several strings and lists in it and this
is actually we literally took the
standard library code and just added
type annotations and the speed-up was
dramatic it was 10x actually for this
function so and if you run this function
a lot that can certainly get you a lot
of the way there but you'll note that
even if it's 10x faster I'm still only
running it on one core and so there's no
way for me to scale this out okay so
let's see how we could actually move up
the complexity curve and scale it out I
now made my URL parse function really
fast as fast as it can get with scythe
on because that's now compiled way down
to the machine right what can I do next
well python 3 and back ported to Python
2 has a concurrent futures API and it
has a pretty good map API which can help
you get some parallelism to your code
but it has some odd implementation
details so we're gonna walk through
those right now so first of all if I
create an executor from concurrent off
futures which is a thread pool executor
and I map URL parse against those URLs
how many cores am I using well it's just
one again right cuz it's the Gil this is
the problem I described earlier thread
pool executors creates a set of threads
to execute but now I'm actually getting
worse performance than the original
example that I showed you guys even
though I've added this fancy executor to
the mix because CPU to bound tasks
actually get worse when you try to map
them over
so what I could do is I could switch the
thread pool executors to a process pool
executor
and now I actually get sort of what I
want I get two cores utilized but the
diagram gets quite a bit more
complicated and I actually find that
like most people who use process pool
executors they're not even really sure
what's happening but some people know
but what's actually happening is is that
you're getting to Python sub processes
via the OS fork call but that only
happens on UNIX so do people here
already know like how many people here
know already about copy-on-write
semantics with OS dot fork yeah so I'm
seeing like one or two hands go up but
yet that is like the key thing about why
this works at all and it's a weird
implementation detail that's why I put
here be dragons at the bottom right
what's actually going on is that when
that process pool executor is running on
UNIX only and not on Windows you're
going to get two python sub processes
which inherit the state from the primary
process that kicked them off and that's
thanks to a system called that's called
Fork so if you like go and whip open
your like 1968 advanced UNIX programming
book you'll find like the the
description of how fork works right
which is a very old but useful tool in
the UNIX world and basically what this
will do is it'll make it so that the
Python sub processes if they have bout
if they are bound to any Global's in
your Python program you are lucky in
that you can still reference those
Global's because you've inherited the
state from the forked off primary parent
process but the problem is that in order
for you to do any computation on these
two sub processes which are running on
separate cores you have to pickle all of
your arguments for any function you map
over and the sub processes have to
pickle the results that they might send
back to your top process so actually
that map call that you see up there it's
running code inside the parent process
but it's receiving pickled results from
the sub processes and this imposes like
all sorts of new requirements on your
program I mean a slew of new
requirements but let's remember even
though I'm now able to use those two
cores those two greyed out servers over
there with other cores available I'm
still not able to use those
so even though I've taken out a whole
lot of more complexity things have
gotten a little bit complicated now who
here has already used multiprocessing or
a process pool executor before okay and
who here has hit an exception stacktrace
after using it that you didn't
understand quite a few people right so
that's because this model is kind of
complicated fork/join in general
introduces all these requirements that
are not typical for Python programs and
so I actually recommend that if you make
the jump to process pool executors or
multi processing and you're a PI data
person you should probably take a look
at job Lib actually and job leaves a
library that's widely used in the
sidekick community but is also like a
kind of standalone module and the way I
think of it is that job Lib can take
that same function map it over your
local machine cores but it actually
cleans up some of the standard library
facilities around multi-processing and
I'll tell you how so this is what a job
Lib program looks like in the top right
you essentially create this parallel
object and instead of doing dot map
although you could probably write a map
like API on top of it the way job Lib
chose to do it is they actually give you
this delayed decorator and the delayed
decorator basically lets you take a
function and say instead of calling this
function when you call it return a three
tuple of the function and it's
positional arguments and it's keyword
arguments in other words don't call the
function describe the function call of
the function that's what it's asking me
to do and then basically when you call
into the parallel object if you use that
delayed object you can basically send
work to your parallel processors in that
same way so it kind of has like a nicer
maybe more maybe somewhat more pythonic
look and feel when you describe it this
way but the key thing that's different
is that it's cleaning up all this multi
processing facility for you in several
ways so one way in which it's doing it
is that it will actually eagerly try to
pickle your arguments and return and
return value for like the early data
samples in your submission so that you
catch that bug before like everything
comes crashing to the ground because
that is like a new requirement of using
this facility the other thing it'll do
is that one of the like major problem
with multiprocessing in general is that
there's IPC overhead every time you make
a function call you have to actually
send data to those sub processes and
what job Lib will do as of recent
versions is it'll measure how long those
individual calls are taking and batch
together small ones together to speed up
your multi processing result overall so
basically it would be like if someone
took multi processing and said I accept
it for all its faults and warts but I'm
going to try to offer like a usable API
on top of it on top of that it also adds
logging better debugging support better
exception trace facts when things go
wrong and a very handy feature which is
that if you set n jobs equal to one then
the job Lib library will simply not use
multi processing or any parallel
processing code at all which will let
you isolate and debug any like parallel
programming problems in your code so I
basically if you're if you're going
process pool executors and multi
processing you should probably upgrade
to job live and and save yourself some
trouble okay so where we ended up here
is we're now still maxing out the cores
on one machine but we still got about a
hundred and forty five terabytes worth
of data to process and only a day to do
it so how do we like actually get on to
multi core multi node and going next
step up into the complexity curve I
think is the I pipe parallel project so
probably like everyone here because
you're at PI data have used ipython
before probably fewer of you know that
ipython bundles like a parallel
computing framework inside of it and
probably yet fewer of you know that
recently this project was spun out into
its own project and so as a result you
can like use it on projects even if
you're not actually using ipython
notebook for parallelism so what does
this project actually do the way I think
of it is that it lets you do that same
mapping but you can map functions over a
pet cluster that you set up your own
little cluster so the diagram gets a
little bit more complicated but here's
what's happening if you create an IP
parallel client you're going to get back
an object which represents a remote
client over your cluster and the only
setup work you have to do is you have to
run a program called IP engine
every one of your cluster nodes and
there's a little bit of setup to this
but it's really lightweight actually
it's pretty nice you set up IP engine on
every one of your cluster nodes and you
set up IP controller on your driver node
and these guys know how to talk to each
other over 0nq and basically they're
running separate Python interpreters
typically one per core that are just
sitting there waiting for work and you
can just send them whatever work you
want and what you see up there at the
top the RC map sync call it's kind of an
interesting syntax if you if you look at
RC itself what it is is a client over
your cluster and you can index into that
cluster to get specific Python engines
or you can use the slice all syntax here
which is like just the colon on its own
and that basically says give me all my
engines okay and then you take all your
engines and you can execute map sync on
them or map a sync there's a whole bunch
of options and basically this works from
a pickle standpoint it works similarly
to multi processing it's still pickling
arguments is still sending code over the
wire but unlike that that other
framework it's not using any of this
forking or Python sub process stuff and
instead it's just shipping your
functions over to these nodes executing
them and getting back the results and so
you're able to use all the cores on your
cluster if you set this up correctly
which is pretty nice so that's that's
kind of like in my kind of logical way
of describing it this is the way the
ipython project itself describes it
there's like a logical layer of your
notebook or driver program the
controller and a bunch of engines and
then there's a physical architecture
which is the client the cluster head and
then a bunch of workers and essentially
the engines map to workers the
controller maps to the cluster head and
your notebook is using that remote
client or it doesn't have to be a
notebook it can be whatever Python code
you want so yeah that's the next level
up in complexity okay so now we're gonna
go kind of perhaps even further up the
curve and start to get to ok what if I
have this data and and I want to scale
it up but I also want to process it as
it's coming in
and I want to do that in a multi-core
fashion so for this actually the the
project that is sort of a shameless self
plug is PI Kafka which my team at
parsley maintains and basically what
this project does is it gives you a
Python API on a open source Apache
project that's called Apache Kafka so if
we go back to this diagram okay it's
taking a second oh okay
doesn't like me for some reason yeah
this diagram here it's kind of weird
let's pull that up once more
bizarre okay I'll just let that load in
the background while I describe
something hopefully it'll actually
render let's see yeah I've got weird so
if we go back to this diagram one of the
things that isn't visualized here is the
way the data flows from Python no to
Python node and essentially what's going
on is that the pet cluster that I PI
parallel helps you set up is
automatically wired with some 0 and Q
Network channels such that when you send
when you send that a request over the
remote client it's actually going to
push that over to all of these engines
and do some processing now what I find
is that in practice if you want to like
actually get the same kind of multi-core
working over a streaming data set you
have to start thinking about you know
how do I do this kind of all the time
right in the case of ipython parallel
it's I've got my cluster running maybe I
have my data set over here and I I
submit individual function calls over
the wire but what if I just want to
constantly in always do multi-core
processing on data that's coming in so
this is a problem that PI Kafka and
Kafka can actually help you solve your
server setup will actually be pretty
similar you'll have a Python process set
up per core on your node but the
interesting thing is that all of these
Python processes can run the same loop
and the loop is up at the top right here
it's a PI Kafka loop of doing
essentially in a tight loop consuming
from a PI Kafka topic or Kafka topic and
then simply running that URL parse
function across it now this is the
interesting thing
there's Message Queuing libraries out
there but I think Kafka is one of the
most interesting for helping Python
programmers with this problem because it
has the support for what's known as
balanced multi consumer operation which
basically means that if I have a single
Python process in the top left that
sends as much data as fast as it can
into a Kafka topic I can have n
consumers on the bottom that read
partitions of that data as fast as they
can on that topic and that means that
those n consumers each of which can be
bound to a separate core are doing
single core processing and thus not deal
neither with gill issues nor with
multi-threaded issues essentially Kafka
has taken on the shared state access
problem at the server infrastructure
level and you're able to take on the
multi-core processing problem at the
programmer code level that makes sense
so I put a little mr. clean logo down
here because one of the things I like
about this set up if you set this up
correctly is this is just Python
processes with no coordination running
on separate machines and separate cores
and each getting their own slice of the
data and there's like no magic
there's no pickling there's no you know
remote code being submitted to different
machines all there is is code running
reading a data source which you can pick
the serialization format of and you can
fully understand and doing that
multi-core processing in parallel and
this is something that we only got
working in PI Kafka basically in the
last six months but it works really well
at scale yeah go ahead you can you can
actually do whatever you like with it
right so you can put it back on a Kafka
topic and then read it that's that's a
very common thing right or you can if
your results are small enough you know
you can just process those from a single
node it depends on what you're doing I
guess if you were to re-implement the I
PI parallel example in this then you
would probably assume that the results
are much smaller than what's being
processed and so it's okay to just read
them off of a topic at the end from a
single node yeah good yeah that's a
great question so you just repeat the
question you asked whether there's any
way to support multiple writers multiple
clients writing to this thing and any
prioritization scheme for eating the
data off of those and the answer is that
that can be done by your code the
generic model that Kafka offers is
basically there are what are known as
topics and consumer groups so topics are
places where data gets written and
consumer groups are groups of processes
that are
gather as a group eating that data and
so you can have multiple consumer groups
per topic and you can have multiple
topics per kafka cluster and so you
could associate priorities with those if
you wanted to it's not something that's
like built-in though yeah yeah go ahead
yeah so the difference is when you set
up things this way
you're basically writing you're running
that top right code on every node right
but instead of like submitting the
arbitrary work to it you would probably
just deploy that to every node and read
from it but the good news is that every
node gets its own partition of the data
and so you're able to light up all your
cores while you're processing all of
that data and that's even if you only
have a single high-speed stream of data
coming in your own program correct yeah
yeah so this is you're not able to
handle every scenario here right so what
you're describing with global state is
like it is technically possible and for
example I PI parallel to have your
engines modify Global's you know to
cache things and stuff so that the
future computations might leverage that
a bit that would not be true here right
although I'll describe how to make these
more stateful in a second right but in
this like simplified architecture that
wouldn't be true cool other questions
okay so this is sort of what the multi
consumer queue looks like for Kafka and
I guess one of the nice things about
when you when you set things up this way
is that each one of those six Python
processes shone on the prior slide are
getting a partition of the data but
there's also some coordination going on
such that if any of those die the
partitions that that consumer owned now
gets shifted over to other consumers so
one of the things I also noticed is that
you know very quickly when you start
getting into large-scale data problems
you start having to worry a little bit
about fault tolerance right like if
you're running on multiple machines you
have to worry about will those machines
be reclaimed will they die and in the
case of AI pi parallel you basically
don't have any help with that likewise
in the case of of course like job Lib or
multi processing but in the case of
Kafka you get a little bit of help if if
a machine dies the other consumers get
to take over and processing continues so
that's like a good primitive way to
think about the fault problem now the
other thing that my team started working
on and this gets to one of the earlier
questions which is okay you're showing a
diagram but essentially you have code
you have arbitrary code running on every
machine how do I make it so that I can
submit code to those machines to run
while still getting the same you know
benefit of what you just described with
Kafka and the kind of pair of
technologies that people have been using
together for this are storm in Kafka and
so my team actually released a module
just a few months ago that's called Pye
storm which actually came out of another
module we wrote called stream parse and
essentially what Pye storm does is offer
an API that helps you map a stream of
inputs to generate a stream of outputs
and it makes use of this open source
storm project which is in the Apache
community as well but it binds it all up
beautifully so that you can just use it
from Python without having to know about
Java right and so this is essentially
what PI storm looks like what a fully
functioning PI storm cluster would look
like you would typically use Kafka to
provide the data source to storm
although that's not required and you
would basically have a short description
in the top right here
which describes that for this URL
problem I have this URL problem we've
been working with this whole time I have
a spout that generates data and a spout
is a storm term for something that
generates data like the PI Kafka
producer that I mentioned before and
then I have a bolt which consumes the
data and parses it and this little
Python DSL here is actually something
we've been working on
last few weeks and that colleague of
mine Dan Blanchard will be presenting
the results of this afternoon and his
talk on stream parse which is like going
more directly into the stream parse
example but basically what's going on is
we take our function we write it into a
little API and we lay it out and we say
hey I can run I can basically run the
URL parse function with a parallelism of
four and I can produce the the data the
URL data with a parallelism of 1 and
storm will like arbitrarily send this
code after the cluster and run it with
these parallelism levels so what you'll
notice is that if you add up the peas P
equals 1 and P equals 4 I get 5 and that
basically means that now there are 5
Python processes running on my cluster
and I can tweak those settings and I get
more processes and each of those
processes get access to the appropriate
code to actually run this stuff and just
like before our Kafka sending data into
the system and storm is able to take
care of communicating between them so
storm is like its own little subject but
basically what you can think of from a
complexity curve standpoint is that
whereas Kafka lets you go multi-core
honest on a big stream of data balancing
the consuming of it storm lets you do
the same thing but also balanced your
computation and do arbitrary computation
on the cluster against the same stream
and it has some built in support for all
the fault tolerance guarantees that we
were talking about before so the last
one I'll mention is probably one I don't
know yesterday someone mentioned this to
me today that yesterday SPARC was
claimed to be the most hyped technology
of this year I guess or of the pi PI
data community but the last one I'll
mention is PI SPARC and I think PI SPARC
got really good support or basically
SPARC got really good support for Python
only relatively recently like in the
last year and the way I think about PI
SPARC is that it helps you map functions
over a data set representation to
perform transformations and actions on
that data so it kind of ends up looking
a little bit like the like the storm
example but also a bit different from an
API standpoint and from the data source
standpoint so how many people here have
already you
spar cuz I wonder what the popularity is
oh wow so it's already like a pretty
good pretty well taken so for you guys
this will be old hat but here's a very
simple spark example up at the top I
load a big heap of files of date I have
a bunch of files in this like files list
I load those using text file then I map
URL parse over them and then I have to
call take one in order to like actually
execute the cluster and that's what
happens and people who use spark
regularly they learn about the fact that
similarly to like I PI parallel and some
of these other solutions you have to
worry about serialization and IPC again
right it gets even more complicated
because there's a Java layer with
serialization going on and a Python
layer but essentially what's happening
is again it's serializing your code
using not quite pickle but actually this
other library called cloud pickle which
is like an upgraded version of pickle
that supports some more stuff like
modules and and lambdas and things and
it sends the code out to your cluster
and then what you notice here I put
Amazon s3 as an example because it's
like probably one of the more common
data sources for SPARC but what you
notice here is that I submit my code to
the cluster but typically with SPARC the
driver doesn't actually help with
getting the data to the cluster instead
what SPARC typically does is the code
knows about how to access the data and
that's actually part of the parallel
computation that it does so the text
file call that I did up there is
basically telling SPARC hey if I've got
a thousand files sitting in s3 which are
a big heap of data each of those Python
processes will get a partition of that
data and they will process those in
parallel and the serialization or
communication mechanisms for SPARC are
PI for J for the driver program
communication and then binary pipes
between Python worker processes and the
JVM that's actually doing some of the
serialization so it's a little bit again
higher up on the complexity curve to
really understand how this thing works
but the good news is that that program
will paralyze using as many cores as you
throw at it and sparks real advantage in
the market is that if you're working
against data at rest you can
Ronis out a cluster that you even resize
while the computation is running and
spark will actually be able to do things
like scale out and eat as many cores as
your cluster gets even while you're
already burning up the cores that you
have right so you don't have to like
resubmit your job to get higher levels
of parallelism so that can be quite nice
this is a good diagram that kind of
summarizes the data flow in spark
basically the spark context talks to a
JVM on the driver program or on the
driver node which is sometimes called
the local node and then spark workers
are JVMs the talk via pipes to python
processes each of which are using a core
right and each of which are letting you
essentially work around the gill at
cluster scale so going back to the
subtitle of my talk I we are currently
at parsley kind of fortunate enough to
be finding that multi-core which storm
works relatively well so this is
somewhat scary thing to do live but I
just SSH tin to our live storm cluster
and this is all Python processes running
all the time against a real-time stream
of data and if I actually look here you
can see that there are all these Python
processes running the stream parse
module which is stream parts basically
scaling 32 cores of computation out
against a stream and we're doing this on
a number of nodes and if you actually
look at the storm UI which is the nice
little admin interface they give you for
this you can sort of see well I'll show
this stupid whiz-bang thing of the storm
UI which is you can sort of see the the
layout of our topology which is like how
the code is running and basically
there's a Kafka stream coming in and
then a whole bunch of Python processing
steps each of which can be parallelized
independently at the cluster scale and
the programming model stays pretty
simple so that's nice the other thing
was I mentioned that we went up to 3,000
cores so for that we actually used spark
and Amazon's new support in EMR for
spark for the new spark versions which
support pi
bark and we use that in order to buy a
bunch of spot instances to reprocess
that 153 terabytes of data so what
you're actually seeing here is the EMR
interface from Amazon and right now this
cluster has six nodes running each of
which I think has 32 cores but if you
simply click that resize button at the
top right while you're processing is
running you can change that six to a
sixty or a 600 depending on how much
cash you have and and it will actually
run that much faster
in fact like we notice that SPARC does
very well at distributing the work this
is a visualization they have in the UI
where they were able to yeah fine that's
cool
wood they were able to kind of spread
this load equally across the cluster and
this is a screenshot from a deploy we
did where we finally got like our
rebuild job working and it was running
across many many hundreds of cores at
once and then once we like realized how
long the job would take we turned the
cluster up to just finish the job in
time right so so yeah that's pretty much
that's pretty much the complexity curve
as I see it right now so I'll just wrap
up by closing up with a couple of things
one is that over time this is the sort
of quote-unquote lambda architecture
we've had to build that parsley to deal
with these problems we basically have
storm being used on the real-time path
and SPARC being used on the batch path
and we have Amazon s3 holding our data
at rest and Kafka holding our data in
motion and if you set this up the good
news is this is the good news the bad
news is there's like two systems each
running which is like AK that stinks but
the good news is that both of these
systems now as of this year have awesome
Python api's and so you can reuse the
code across both of these systems which
was not true a while back we built the
Python API for storm and thankfully the
SPARC team built it for SPARC so we
didn't have to build that one which is
nice and so this is sort of the overall
kind of high-level technology stack we
used there's a batch layer with SPARC in
s3 storm and Kafka and the speed layer
and then the end product the kind of
place where we write the data is
actually elasticsearch in Cassandra
but that's like not that interesting
okay so parting thoughts right where
I've sort of ended up on all this stuff
is uh I went back and read the famous
article from unfortunately the
now-defunct dr. Dobbs Journal that was
about the free lunches over who here has
read the free lunch is over oh not that
many you guys should go back and find it
if you haven't it's a little bit of an
oldie but goodie there's a chart in
there that basically shows this graph
and this graph indicates that over time
although processing power is increasing
we're also getting a plateau of the
essentially the megahertz of each core
that we have and so the free lunch is
over is essentially a statement about
hey multi-core is upon us and I think
the article suggests everyone needs to
get on multi-core the way C++ has or
something like that right because it was
written a few years ago but I actually
think that this is the free lunch that's
actually over so this is a graph from
one of Amazon Web Services a blog posts
and actually the y-axis of this graph is
or it's only the x-axis of this graph is
actually just a week it's seven days of
activity on Amazon ec2 and the red line
is the number of ec2 instances that
Animoto had to spin up to handle the
processing load that they were handling
and it starts at 40 instances down there
and peaks at 5,000 up there so in my
mind it's not that the free lunch is
over on multi-core it's that the free
lunch is over on single node right and
and so for in my mind I say we should
always look to word multi-process not
multi-threading we should look at multi
node not multi-core and we should look
at message passing not shared memory
because in this world we're basically
dealing with heaps of data and streams
of data that we can't scale up on single
machines easily there are some other
communities that are thinking about this
problem I like that when I presented
stream parse at PyCon Titus Brown
actually wrote but what about Erlang on
Twitter and I think if you look at the
Erlang community there's some
interesting stuff going on there and
recently in the elixir community with
this but my conclusion for this talk and
maybe the takeaway I hope you take away
from it is that Gil is actually a
feature not a bug
instead of trying continuing to try to
work around it it's saving us
from the work of having to figure out
how to scale up on multi-core on a
single node if we instead invest that
same effort and how to scale up on multi
on multiple cores across multiple nodes
we're actually going to defeat the
challenges that we have ahead so if you
want to help out with that effort there
are open source projects like PI store
and pi copy and stream parse you can
look at but that's all I've got